our generation was meant to inherit the
Stars
found the lost the only surviving member
of the house about
[Music]
the blood of house L will always bind us
together
[Music]
everybody there's a whole bunch of
Superman mythos stuff to break down we
have the Krypton prequel stuff that's
coming I'll explain when that's
premiering what's going on with that
series as well as Brainiac 5 who is now
a character in the DC TV universe so two
completely separate things like we
actually might see Brainiac show up on
the Krypton show but because that's
taking place a couple hundred years
before the events in present-day it
would be like the proto coluan version
of Brainiac not Brainiac five who were
getting ready to see who's a clone of a
version of Brainiac so I know it gets a
little confusing when you're talking
about Brainiac because he exists in
multiple different versions
simultaneously and there's all kinds of
comic-book stuff that got really
confusing with the new 52 and
convergence so don't worry about any of
that because so many of you have been
requesting that I do it there'll be a
legion flight ring giveaway for all the
superman related stuff that's going on
so anything that's non flash DC video
that's legion flight ring so be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos so if
you're not sure what's going on or you
don't watch Supergirl on the 15th
Brainiac is making his entrance he's
going to help them bring Supergirl out
of the coma that she got her ass beaten
into by rain during the mid-season
finale
[Music]
so if you've never watched Supergirl
before I would recommend that you check
out episode 10 just so you can see what
a version of Brainiac looks like in the
DC TV universe their version of the
character actually looks like it's more
inspired by the Justice League Unlimited
animated version who did have some sort
of relationship with Supergirl when he
came on that series I think it was like
season 3 episode 10 all of our teammates
have been captured to save them we'll
have to break the laws of time and
recruit heroes from the past but messing
with history that's risky even for us
now this boy Kara likes so much does he
have a name but even though there's been
evil and good versions of him depending
on which era of the comics you're
reading he's the one that created the
legion flight ring and it sounds like
they might play it back and forth a
little bit like make you wonder if he
ever might become evil just because he's
Brainiac they tend to have fun with
stuff like that and you may remember
when the show was still on CBS they did
a version of indigo played by the
Supergirl from Smallville now that's
more Brainiac aid so she's like an evil
version of the character from a future
timeline so remember how I said the
timeline gets kind of confusing when
you're talking about Brainiac because
Brainiac 5 is from the 31st century
indigo Brainiac 8 existed during present
day she had been trapped in the Phantom
Zone so just don't worry about it too
much we could talk about indigo when I
do my video for the episode because
Legion of super-heroes is a pretty big
deal we learned about ma Nell being
sucked into the future 31st century but
they found out that something terrible
happened it sounds like they knew that
rain was going to come and destroy the
earth so they wanted to come back in
time to help Supergirl but they came
back in time too far so now everybody is
slowly waking up from these pods
everybody in the pods is a member of the
Legion of super-heroes we have Saturn
girl ma Nell and now Brainiac 5 it
remains to be seen which other
characters are going to introduce
because the Legion is a really big group
of people but for those of you that are
like what the hell is up with brainiacs
look why does he look like a total freak
I think that's because they want you to
be a little afraid of the character
because you don't know whether he's
gonna be good or he's going to be evil
even though he's a good character I
don't know how many episodes they're
going
to be in but I'm assuming that they'll
have something to do with helping them
defeat rain so I think part or most of
the Legion will be around for the rest
of the season on Supergirl
but that is probably where we get our
first legion flight ring but they
haven't explained because Superman has a
legion flight ring in the fortress of
solitude so they'll probably sew up some
of that logic like oh this is where he
got it from but moving into Superman
Krypton prequel territories so if you
didn't know it's kind of like Terminator
Sarah Connor Chronicles it's a time
travel story with somebody trying to
mess up Superman's timeline so that he
never winds up becoming Superman and it
destroys the earth and in order to do
that this mystery person that we're
gonna find out about over the course of
season 1 travels back in time a couple
hundred years to Krypton and just messes
with his family so it's all about
Superman's grandfather sag l played by
this character fixing his family fixing
his heritage so like you see them
entering the proto version of the
fortress of solitude they announced that
it's gonna premiere on March 21st now
that's a Wednesday so I'm assuming that
it's always going to be a Wednesday
night show they haven't said what time
it's gonna air at but most sci-fi series
like magicians air at around 9:00 p.m.
so I'm assuming that's when it's gonna
be there aren't any other Wednesday TV
shows that I do videos for so it should
be pretty easy I think there's only
gonna be 13 episodes in season 1 and I
am assuming they're just gonna air all
13 without any breaks but we'll find out
more about that as we get a little bit
closer they'll release more trailers
right now we really only have a couple
of teasers so if you weren't sure what
was going on with Krypton its Adam
Strange in present day finding out that
someone is messing with Superman's
timeline like he just winks out of
existence so he goes back in time to
help Superman's family fix their
timeline but because we're in outer
space and we're back in time a couple
hundred years they tease crossover like
obviously Adam Strange is a crossover
character but they tease some Hawke
world stuff they tease that there would
be some other characters from the
Superman mythos that we show up but the
big ones that they revealed are Hawkgirl
doomsday in charas who's actually in
Amazonian so I don't know how they're
gonna work in the Wonder Woman mythos to
ancient Krypton
but it should be pretty interesting like
if you saw Justice League they had that
pre credit sequence where they're all
battling Steppenwolf Bob
they'll probably find some interesting
way of weaving that in but if you've
ever watched any version of the Superman
mythos they've teased that Kryptonians
visited earth a long time before
Superman himself ever landed on earth
like that's how the scoutship in Man of
Steel wound up there because a long time
ago Kryptonians used to be a race of
explorers so when we get closer to the
series I'll revisit that jor-el
pre-credit sequence in Man of Steel
because he sort of tells their history
where it was like we used to be these
grand explorers but things change we
became more isolated more xenophobic and
then that led to our downfall so you
have any big questions about what's
going on with DC TV stuff like Brainiac
5 or the Krypton series Superman stuff
just let me know in the comments but
there's still a lot of news that they'll
be announcing because the tcas for DC TV
is this Sunday so I'll be doing a video
for that they'll probably announce which
series are gonna be renewed and we'll
probably find out about the new comic
book TV shows that are premiering this
year I'm hoping to get some news about
the Deadpool TV series but we'll see
about that
and we're also supposed to get a legion
season 2 trailer so just like a whole
bunch of TV stuff dropping really soon
so just be on high alert for trailers to
be dropping there's a new round of the
legion flight ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just share the video using the YouTube
tools on the watch page here
congratulations to the winner from my
last video s rack of lamb please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for brand new flash
footage and click here to learn about
the big changes they just announced for
the DC movie universe thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight